Hello!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hello, everybody!
Hello!
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I know, like, I baited you guys, uh, for those who were waiting for, like, I don't know, maybe 15 plus hours for Elden Ring because I did make my waiting room super early because I- I legit thought I was gonna play Elden Ring today.
I- I was like, oh, if anything, at least I know I'm playing Elden Ring tomorrow.
But, like, whoops.
It's just a chatting stream now.
Um, okay.
So now some of you guys are wondering, okay, before I talk about other stuff, some of you guys are wondering, oh, Adoki, why are you not showing the rest of your- the rest of your head?
Well, I was gonna show it on Elden Ring, but I was like, you know, since I'm just chatting, then I have a better showcase for this.
But, we finally got the update, guys.
Yes.
As in nothing.
No, I'm sorry.
Oh, yes.
We finally- Whoa!
Wait, this changed.
Whoa!
Yes.
We finally got the update.
The long hair- Long hair Doki!
Yeah!
Yes.
Watch this.
Oh, short hair.
Long hair.
Short hair.
I just magically grew longer hair.
Like- Or maybe they're extensions.
I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
I'm just clipping all my extensions.
No extensions.
Extensions.
Extensions!
But, yes.
We finally- Um...
We finally got the update today.
Avalian, thank you for the- Five gifted chefs.
Thank you.
Doki.
Let down your golden hair.
If only it were- It's just like- I'm just putting on- Oh, you're right.
I should- Wait, what- Where is it?
You're right.
I should try it.
Where is it?
Is it this one?
No.
Wait, where is- It's this one.
What does it look like?
That's what it looks like with the long neck, too.
Uh, Tom.
Thank you for the five gifted chefs.
Thank you.
Um...
Is it perfection?
I know.
It's absolutely perfect.
As it meant to be.
Um...
I love my maidenless ex-Fujo Kamiyoshi.
Thank you.
I'm glad everyone agrees with me that I am an ex-Fujo.
Oh, man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Zyko.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Let me, uh, put it back down.
I mean, it was a perfect time to- To show the- To showcase the long hair.
But yes!
Um, we finally got it.
Yippee!
Um...
But, okay.
What was I talking about earlier today?
Before- Oh, yes!
Uh...
Yes, I had to change- It was either cancel the stream or just do a chatting stream.
Because I have- Right now, I- Really have no energy to play a game at the moment.
Or, like, do a long stream.
I- I- I just had no- Like, I- I wouldn't say play a game.
I would say I just didn't have the energy to do a long stream today.
And I knew that if I was gonna play Eldering today, It was gonna be a very long stream.
Because I've been, like, working up non-stop behind the scenes the last, uh, two days.
And I have to work more today as well.
So, this week is, like, super chonky.
It's- It's- Um...
Um...
But, yes.
I'm warning you guys right now.
I'm gonna be a NASCAR for a week.
For those who are like, What the fuck do you mean?
Okay, so you know how NASCAR's, They have, like, all these ads and everything plastered all over the place?
Okay.
So, it was very unfortunate timing.
Because, um, It would have to look less like a NASCAR If, like, I didn't have to move a sponsor stream from next week To this week.
So, um...
So, basically, yeah.
It's this week.
Okay, it's literally, like, three...
Maybe four back-to-back.
These are just sponsors!
It's- It's- It's a little- It's a little unfortunate with how everything's scheduled.
But, like, it was- It was partially my fault.
Because I had to move stuff around.
Um...
Okay, I'll give you guys, uh...
Oh, yeah.
We're- Okay.
So, like, um...
So, alright.
Tuesday and Wednesday is our basically rest- Like, not- Not chilling time.
But, Thursday, we have two things.
I'll give you guys the schedule.
So, Thursday, there- We have a sponsored game in the morning.
And in the- In the evening, we have the, uh...
Vite Ramen, uh, collab.
Where we're doing the- The launch of our merch.
With Vite Ramen.
It's technically, it's sponsors.
It's a sponsor thing.
Well, uh, technically, it's sort of sponsored.
Because I'm shilling my merch.
Uh, uh, uh, with Vite Ramen.
Uh, for those who don't know what Vite Ramen is.
It's, like, um...
They basically make, like, cooking stuff.
So, like, uh, there's, like, cooking.
Uh, like, you know, I think you guys are- Some of the videos and teasers are already released.
So, there's one with the- Like, the Doki board with a cutting board and everything.
Um, so- So, Thursday, it's a double- A double whammy.
Friday!
There is a special sponsor stream.
Um, because they, like, message- I told you guys about the sponsor stream before.
Like, it's from- Uh, I can't reveal it yet.
Because they- They want to tweet it out first before they reveal it.
But it's for a game that I play a lot.
So, like, hint, hint.
Like- So, they reached out to me.
Last week, if I wanted to be in it.
And I was like, oh, fuck yeah, of course.
Um, yeah, of course I would love to be in it.
And, uh, so, that's Friday.
And then, after that, I'll do Elder Ring after that.
So, it doesn't seem like it's all sponsors.
And then, on Saturday, I'm sponsored to play the fake trigger tournament.
The anime girl battle royale game.
Um, so, on Saturday, I am also- I'm also sponsored to be in that tournament.
Um, coincidentally, they actually put, like, uh, all the people- Like, they're like, oh, we want to make sure- We just want to put Doki with people that she know.
And then, all the people that they sponsored for it were also people I know.
So, so, I'm on a team with Sure4, RPR, and Albert Lele.
So, that's- It's funny, because I was like, wait, we're all sponsored to be.
Like- So, it's, uh, so, that's a fake trigger tournament.
And, if we do well, uh, we have to be there for day two, which is on Sunday.
Uh, so, so, I'm just like, so, it could potentially be a four-day back-to-back-to-back-to-back sponsored week.
If we, like, make it- If we do well on Saturday and make it to the next round, we will have to show up on the second day.
Because, obviously, that's the finals.
So, so, so, oh, no, sounds terrible.
Money, money, money.
So, um, uh, so, that's, that's, that's NASCAR week for us.
That's gonna be, uh, that's gonna, it's gonna be NASCAR week.
So, it's start- NASCAR week starts on Thursday.
Um, we are, we do have, like, a little, like, break, you know, with the, in the pit.
Where we get to play Elden Ring a little bit on Friday.
After this, also, by the way, Friday and Saturday sponsors are gonna be on Twitch, too.
Because of Twitch drops.
Um, um, so, uh, Friday, we'll be on Twitch.
You know, the first stream, what, the special stream for those, uh, quote-unquote, don't know.
Oh, what could it be?
Uh, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Oh my gosh, what could the special stream on Friday be?
Um, with Twitch drops.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
I can't say it.
They're like, no, no, no, no, don't say anything.
I was like, okay.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Uh, uh, but, um, it'll be on, uh, it'll be on Friday, Twitch drops.
And then Saturday, there's also Twitch drops for the tournament as well.
Uh, so, it's definitely Rocket League.
Yeah, totally.
A hundred.
I've never, I've actually never played Rocket League before.
Um, surprisingly.
Oh yeah, I forgot to show you guys what it looks like with, um, with the hoodie up, too.
Yay, oh, it's so cute.
I actually never, I actually never seen it with the hoodie up, too.
I, oh, wait, this actually is so cute with the hoodie up.
Whoa.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
This is actually my first time.
See, I'm experiencing it with you guys, too.
Uh, ha, ha, ha.
I literally, they got the file.
They got the new skin suit, and I just plopped it on right before stream.
I didn't even check it out at all.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
I just, I just plopped it on, and it's like, all right, it's time.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Uh, which one do you guys want?
Tomato or Dragoon Hoodie?
Which one do you guys like more?
Chat.
Tomato or Dragoon Hoodie more?
Which one?
You guys get to decide.
I'll let you guys fight for it.
Forbidden!
Thank, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome, tomato!
Okay, we'll do tomato.
All right, down or up?
Uh.
Hmm.
I think.
Oh, it's cute.
Yeah.
Uh.
Ooh, maybe I'll do this too.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Um.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Okay, no lollipop.
Um.
Oh, what was I saying?
Uh.
P-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p.
Yeah, uh.
It-it's-it's-it's-it's-it's a little awkward.
Because I-we didn't-we didn't really-we didn't really, like, uh, spread the sponsors for this week.
Because, like I said, everything just happened to align on this week as well.
To be fair, my manager did sign the fake trigger sponsor first.
And then, uh, and then I was-and then, like, my rep-
Cut that out.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Okay.
Oh, we didn't hear that.
We didn't- Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
The-the company.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Edit the vibe.
Edit the quick time.
I can't-I-I may.
Alright, edit-it's okay.
It's just a chatting stream.
I-we don't-we don't-we don't-we don't-we don't-I love-I love-FPS games.
Woo!
Including, for example, Apex Legends, Marvel Rivals, Overwatch.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Overwatch Overwatch.
Uh, um, uh, Fig Trigger's technically a third-person shooter and also Fortnite.
Yeah.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Um, yeah.
Um, anyway.
Anyway, like I said, yeah, everything just happened to, uh, line up together.
Uh, so, uh,
Halo, Val- No, no, Valorant will never be included.
I don't think-I honestly-I don't even think, like, Riot needs to sponsor anyone for League or Valorant because people literally do it for free.
Like, I- I don't think-I don't think they need to sponsor anybody for that.
Um, Uh, BK, BTK.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Shake and Bake Doki.
Remember, if you're not first, you're last- No, you're not- You're last.
Congrats to the sponsors.
Thank you for the, uh, Super Chat.
Thank you.
laughs
Uh, what was I gonna say?
But yeah, I was working on the schedule.
That's why the schedule was super late.
Because we had to wait for confirmation on time slots for everything, basically.
So we had to confirm times.
It's so difficult sometimes to confirm times and everything on a schedule in advance.
Because a lot of times, a lot of these events and stuff... Especially if they're like... If it's not just... If it's just individual sponsors, I get to decide the time and date for things.
But if it's a group sponsor or a group event or stuff like that, usually the confirmation for things are done two to three days before the actual event.
Or maybe four days.
And I have to... Basically, we have to push to figure out the times and everything.
Because like, you know, like a lot of this are... Like, you know, you have to align the schedules with everyone too.
Like, the fake trigger tournament has like... I think like... 12... 11... Wait... 22 teams in there?
And it's 22 teams of four.
I think it's 22.
Let me double check.
It was a lot of teams.
I looked at it.
I was like...
Whoa.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 18, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19...
Oh yeah, it's 22.
It's 22 teams of four.
And like, quick maths.
Somebody quick maths that for me real quick.
So like, you know, they have to align the schedule for like 96 people.
They asked me like, if I wanted to be group A and group B.
Like, they gave me a choice.
And then group A was at 12 p.m.
And obviously, I didn't pick that time.
I... Because like, we have a... Or 88, sorry.
We had a... We have a... A... Look, who said 96?
I literally read the first person.
Endless quietness.
I got one guide by this one...
How did you get 96?
Like, how did you get 90?
There was only one person that said 96, but he was the fastest one.
So obviously, I read his name first.
Anyway.
So, what was I gonna say?
Uh...
He's so confident.
He was so fast too.
Uh...
Eternally.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki's my friend's Vincent's birthday.
Can you please say happy birthday to him?
Of course I can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Vincent.
Yeah!
Happy birthday.
But yeah.
So they're like, you want group A or group B?
And I saw 12pm versus 3pm.
And we all know what happens when I try to play FPS games.
Or like, even just any shooter.
Like, in the morning.
It does not go so well for me.
So...
So I was like, no, fuck that shit.
I'm fucking up with play.
I'm like...
I'm picking group.
I don't know why they asked me specifically.
Um...
I guess like...
Because like...
There's no captains on our team.
Like, we're literally all...
All four of us...
We're sponsored...
Uh...
We're sponsored to join the tournament.
So like...
There's no like actual captain-captain.
But like, apparently I have the most say for our team.
Because they like...
Just specifically asked me if I wanted group A or group B.
And I was like, group B.
Because I don't want to wake up that early on Saturday.
I...
I was like, we're all...
I was...
Because like...
Um...
The tournament is mixed between...
The tournament is mixed between like sign-ups and people who were sponsored.
Um...
I assume.
Because I saw that...
Uh...
The organizer made like a call-out for like teams to sign up and stuff.
So I assume that's the case.
Uh...
But yeah, I'm looking forward to it.
I did try a little bit.
I did try a little bit of the game yesterday.
Yesterday night.
And it's pretty fun.
Um...
It's basically...
Like I said, it's like battle royale.
Battle royale anime girls.
With like abilities and stuff.
So I had a good time checking it out.
Mery, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Finally fulfilling my promise to you.
Paying for your...
Uh...
Loot merch from Offkai.
Also, can we get a green screen of long hair?
Doe kitty version?
Wow, that's a lot of requests, Mery.
Uh...
I'll think about it.
You know, if you just requested green screen, I'd be like, of course, Mery.
But then you were like, I want this and that.
And now I have to think about it, Mery.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Akasupa, the greed.
The greed, yes.
Yes.
You got a little too greedy.
Um...
But yeah.
Uh...
Just a lot of going.
Like I said, like the last...
Oh...
The...
My greed is my talent to fall.
Mery, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, you stepped like...
You were one...
One toe a bit too far the line.
And I was like...
You had one chance, Mery.
And you fumbled it.
Um...
But the last, like...
Two days, it's just been like...
Work, work, work, work, work, work, work.
I was like...
There's so much stuff to do.
Oh my god.
There's so much stuff.
Mery just wanted in on NASCAR week.
Alright, let me see.
Oh!
Okay, also...
Good news about...
Uh...
Good news about the 3D concert.
But...
Uh...
The 3D concert.
But, uh...
Uh...
But...
It will be most likely be out by end of August.
The Polish version.
And...
You are not...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my...
I...
It was so hard to pick the encore song.
You are not ready for the song I've picked.
For the encore.
It could be anything.
It could be...
It could...
It could be anything.
But I feel like...
Whatever it could be...
Whatever you're thinking right now.
That would not be the encore song that actually plays.
It could be anything.
Iridescence, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Are you telling me that infinite oil fairy money doesn't get me everything I want in the world?
No!
Then what's the point in having money?
What's the point?
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Random, thank you for the super chat.
Oh yeah, by the way, for the member goons out there in the Minecraft server, it's back up.
Okay, I may have made a big oopsie when I destroyed everyone.
I may or may not have made a huge oopsie when I Thanos snapped.
We destroyed the entire server inventory system because that has led us to actually...
We had to actually delete the whole server.
We had to delete the whole scene and restart everything.
So, you know when I was like...
You know when I just left?
So, after that...
Remember when I was like, oopsie, and I just left?
And I just left and ended the stream and be like, alright, we'll let the staff figure this out.
So, apparently, from what I was told, um...
From what I was told, um...
They had to basically recreate...
They basically had to like, uh, make an entire new scene.
Uh, because the server was now infinitely broken.
Because we wiped everybody's inventory!
So...
And, because of that, um...
We had to...
Yeah, we had to reconstruct reality for the server.
Um...
And, um...
Okay, I gave the order, but they had their own free will to not listen to me.
So, like, who was at fault here?
They didn't stop and think that maybe that was a bad idea.
Anyway, that's why.
Okay, but, like, you know, sometimes maybe I give bad orders and then it's up to the people below me to check on it.
To make this think, like, is that a good thing to do?
You know, the checks and...
What's the point of having checks and balances if they don't check or balance it?
Anyway...
Um...
So, uh...
Because of that, they had to start an entire new seed.
The server was down for, like, two more days.
And, um...
But now everything's fine.
I think.
I...
Okay, maybe not everything is fine.
But, like...
Um... It's stable now.
It's... It's... It's stable now.
So, for those who have been waiting on the Minecraft server, the members Minecraft server, you can...
It's gone in.
Everything seems to be stable.
Um...
It wasn't at first, um...
What I've heard.
People were being sent to the void, from what I've heard.
But it should be good now.
It's... It's... It should be good now.
Um...
Thank you.
I won't use this ACA request.
You comply with Mehdi's...
Uh, to come... To request you to comply with Mehdi's request.
But only show Dad's a model.
Aren't you?
You know what?
Yeah.
I fuck with that.
You're... You're alright.
You get that.
Alright, let's see.
Where's my green screen?
Technically, not green screen.
Because, like, I have too many colors.
Basically, so...
Um...
It's so hard to figure out what sc... What color to use for the green screen.
Alright.
Does this color work?
I think it does.
Alright.
Hello, Mr. Class President.
What is... What do you want to say today?
The magenta... The magenta screen.
Hello, Mr. Class President.
What wisdom do you want to share to the class?
Let me...
Brian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Too bad, Dragoons.
This twisted games needs to be reset.
We'll start over from zero with this version to entrust the future to the next generation.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Brady Boy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Jokey, last week they went against you and were forced to slay innocent chat members.
I think that's what it's on.
Yeah.
It's not my fault.
They're weak-willed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Um...
Okay.
But I'll...
I'll give you guys this for a little bit.
Hello, everybody.
Uh...
Zero!
Thank you for the magenta super!
Thank you.
Minecraft server team appreciation super.
Thank you for the magenta super.
No.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh yeah, wait.
I have other green screen colors.
Okay.
This one's actually green, but I don't know if that works.
Oh my God.
It's...
That hurts.
This one's dark green, but I also don't know if that works though.
But...
Here's...
Here's dark green, just in case.
I have all the colors.
Uh...
Well, that...
That was it.
That was all...
That was all the colors, guys.
Alright.
Back to the chatting screen.
Where's my chatting screen?
Wow!
Uh...
Here it is.
I'll be back here.
Hello, everybody.
I'm back.
Dark green works?
Okay, that's good to know.
But yeah, it's hard to figure out what color works because I just have too many colors on me.
Uh...
But what else do I want to really update you guys about?
Um...
I haven't been giving much dad updates because he's just been, like, sleeping.
I...
Basically...
Okay, so I ordered a little playpen.
Like, you know, those little children playpen, but for dogs.
Um...
I've had that order, like, uh...
A couple of months ago when he first had his back surgery, but then he recovered really fast.
Like, you know, because I...
I gave him to the dog sitter to look after him for the first two weeks.
And after that, he didn't really need a dog...
Like, he didn't really need to, like, rest anymore.
Or, like, not move.
So, like...
But then, like, you know...
Um...
You know, he's, like, recovering from, um...
His...
Either his...
I hope it's a sprained neck muscle.
Um...
He hasn't really recovered that much.
Since, like, uh...
He's still limping a little bit.
But I just assumed...
Because the vet did say it was four weeks of rest.
So I'm hoping that things will look better...
Within the second or third week.
Um...
But I'm taking him to get a CT scan tomorrow.
Just to be sure.
Uh...
You know, I don't...
I don't want to risk anything.
Um...
So I just...
I'm taking him to get a CT scan tomorrow.
Uh...
But yes, no.
I had to build a fucking playpen for him.
And he's, like, enclosed in his own little baby jail.
Wait, let me...
I took a photo earlier.
Let me see if I can find it.
He's, like, in his fucking little baby jail right now.
Let me see if I have it.
I know I took a photo of this and, like...
Sent it to a friend.
Because I was like...
There he is.
Uh...
Imprisoned for his crimes.
Of...
Of being old, I guess.
I am...
His crimes of being old.
All right.
Let me...
I saved it.
I need a double check if there's, like...
I need a double check to make sure there's, like, no reflections and stuff like that.
Uh...
All right.
His...
His return.
In baby jail.
All right.
This is basically what it looks like.
But it's, it's like, it's literally like a square.
Alright, look it, this is his little baby jail that I like kept him locked up in.
Cause like, I didn't have like an actual cage for him.
Cause they were saying like, oh, just put him in a cage.
And, um, it's not a prison!
It's a retirement home!
Essentially, it's like a retirement home.
Um, dude, it's, and so he won!
That's the whole point!
It's the whole point so he doesn't move, guys!
Uh, he has to, we know if we free him, he'll move!
The whole point is to restrict him from moving!
Uh, I can, um, I can almost pick up the bingo smell.
He free him!
He, it's not my, okay, okay, okay, okay, I swear, okay.
Like, he is so stubborn.
He is so fucking stubborn.
Okay, so I was telling this story to my friend.
Because I was like, I was like, why is he like this?
So, I was, it was just like, you know, it's med time, you know?
It's like, ring, ring, ring!
It's time for your daily meds!
Grandpa!
But, anyway, so I was like, prepping his, like, pills and stuff, his medication, like, his painkillers.
And this fucker was like, because he, he's, he's sometimes he get, like, super excited about his medicine, medication.
Because he gets to have, like, treats and stuff with his medication.
So, he knows.
He's like, yay!
And then, like, because it's, like, neck muscles.
Like, whatever, whatever it is, it relates to his neck muscles.
Um, like, the pain.
And he kept, like, looking up.
And then I hear him crying out while he's, and he does it, like, three times.
I was like, stop looking up!
I was like, what?
Stop!
You know it hurts!
Stop looking up!
Like, he's like, he's like, I wouldn't look at the food!
And he's like, and I'm like, okay, okay, at least it's, like, one time.
And then he doesn't get, it's like, and I'm like, stop!
I was like, it's, I'm just like, please!
I was like, stop!
You're making me worried!
Stop hurting yourself!
Um, is he stupid?
No, the thing is, I wasn't even getting the treats.
I was literally prepping the medication because I had to cut the pills and everything.
I'm like, I'm trying to help you!
Um, uh, ABR, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dad's retirement prison.
Cindy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sent to jail by dictating Toki.
Um, but, like, uh, uh, the good thing is that, um, cause, like, you know when they're, I don't know if you guys know this, but when a dog gets, like, injured or, like, is in, like, pain, a little pain or stuff, they are, like, super submissive.
Um, and they don't want to, like, they're, like, oh, I don't mean, they're, like, oh, I don't mean to, I don't mean to do anything, sir, sorry, I had good, have a nice rest of your day, you know, like, you know, like, you see other dogs and they're, like,
oh, sir, sorry, have a good rest of your day, sir, I didn't mean nothing.
After you, like, they, they don't want to, like, engage or anything with other dogs.
And like... so... Before dad... before like dad got... like got like whatever it is with his neck... I mean no harm, please leave me like that.
So he would always aggress other dogs.
Like he would... like when he's on his... you know when we're walking to the dog park, he always like run... like if he's on a leash and he sees another dog on a leash, he always like runs up to them and aggress them and be like...
Get out of the way!
This is my hallway!
Leave!
Move!
And then like... even when I pick him up, he'd be like... Yes!
Right!
Walk away!
Every time.
Like every fucking time.
And... even the big dogs too.
Even the big dogs.
And then he baits the big dogs.
That's the worst part.
He baits... Actually no, he baits both big dogs and small dogs of all sizes.
Like sometimes he'd be like...
Hi!
I'm friendly!
And then they like...
Walk up to him.
Give... try to give him a sniff on the snout.
And then he's like...
And then he like gets... lets them get closer and he's like... he's like...
GET OUTTA HERE!!!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
And like he barks in his... their faces.
Like the moment they...
Like get close to him.
He's like... Oh hey friend!
And then tries to sniff and he's like...
He's like... FUCK YOU!!!
Like in their faces.
Um...
And... So he would do that.
Like...
He would fucking... He would...
Um... do that sometimes.
But ever since he got like... injured...
He would just be like...
Oh hello!
Ha ha ha!
Oh this... Oh please!
Just... Just walk by!
He he he he!
Oh!
Oh don't... Don't get near me!
If you wanna get near me that's okay!
Just...
It's alright!
Please leave me alone!
Like... Like... Cause he's you know...
He's like... Submissive and stuff cause he's like...
Like... You know he's injured.
And... Um... Anyway!
But... But... Today!
Today!
I was like...
Today he... Um... Because I don't like him walking...
Uh... To the dog park cause I'm trying to like make sure to restrict his movement...
As much as possible.
And... So that's why he's in baby jail right now.
Like... That's why...
That's why he's in baby jail at the moment.
Because we're trying to... I'm trying to restrict as much movement as possible.
And, um... I like how to say we, as in, like, you and I, chat.
Like, as if you're part of this.
Like, no, I'm fucking doing all this myself right now.
I was like, what have you guys been doing, huh?
What have you guys been doing?
What have I tried so hard to fix dad?
Huh, chat?
Huh?
Anyway, um...
Uh, we work.
We give moral support.
But, but, Tokyo, we're a team.
No!
You're right, guys.
I'm sorry.
I'm just, I'm just all over the place, guys.
Emotionally.
I'm sorry.
Anyway, I'm here to collect my child support, guys.
You're right.
I'm sorry, guys.
I forgot about our child support for dad.
Alright.
Anyway, uh...
What was that?
Okay, so, anyway.
Long story.
This was a very long story to tell.
A very short thing.
Anyway, so, uh...
Basically, he, I was, I had him on my arms, and we bumped into another dog, and he started barking at this, the dogs while we were walking past, and I was so happy.
Like, usually I'd be like, why are you like this?
But I'm like, oh my god, yes, there's knife in him.
You know, he was like, I, he's like, oh my, he's feeling it again, guys.
He's actually, um...
Alimony for VTubers' dog.
I hate post-money.
That's right.
Where is the alimony, Chad?
I got it.
How else will we pay for dad's support?
But as nature is healing, he barked at a dog while in my arms.
So, like, I take that as a, I take that as a good sign that he's actually, like, recovering and stuff.
So, yippee!
Um, I'm happy about that.
But yes, there he is in his little prison.
Uh, he's like, finally I have high ground.
He's been having, he's been enjoying it a lot.
Because, like, I usually don't carry him around.
Because I feel like when you carry small dogs around, it gives them a bigger ego.
And, um, what's the word?
It makes them, uh...
What's that word?
It makes them more arrogant.
And more egotistical.
Uh, so that's why I try to avoid...
Uh, because they're, like, I feel like they get more spoiled the higher, the taller they get.
Uh, yeah.
Yeah, they, they, they get, I, I feel like small dogs, when you pick them up too much, they get more over, they get more spoiled and, like, um, arrogant too.
So I, I, or entitled, yeah.
So I try to avoid picking dad up.
Um, so, but, um, lately, you know, uh, he's been loving it.
He's been loving it so much.
He's like, I'm so tall now.
Uh, he, every time I, like, I, like, bent down, he instantly, like, like, jumps into my arms.
And he's like, yippee.
Uh, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
I get to be a tall boy.
Uh,
ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
What's going on with him at the moment?
Uh, he'll be at the dog sitter, uh, tomorrow as well.
Um, just cause, like, you know, he deserves to be spoiled.
He deserves, like, um, you know, he deserves, like, to be, like, extra spoiled.
And he loves a dog sitter.
So I figured, like, um, you know, uh, putting him at the dog sitter would be a good idea.
Uh, b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b.
Yeah, that's why you haven't heard him barking, because the... Okay.
He doesn't wake me up in the morning anymore, which is nice.
I've actually been able to sleep in.
Because his, like, feeding schedule is now... Because of the medication and stuff, like the pain meds.
One of the pain meds gets him a little sedated.
So he makes him, like, super sleepy.
So he's been sleeping in more because of it.
So now, it's really fucked up.
But through medication, we fixed his eating schedule.
So he doesn't wake me up at 6 in the morning anymore.
Like, that was what it took to make it so that I don't have to wake up at 6 in the morning to give him food.
So now, now I can actually wake up at, like, 10 or 11 a.m.
With the... The answer was drugs, Doki.
It's one weakness.
Drugs.
Yeah, so...
So, um...
There's...
So, that's, like...
I guess that's the positive.
I get to...
I get to sleep a little longer now.
Um...
Alright, let me...
I have, like, a list of...
Updates and stuff.
Uh...
Oh, yeah.
Um...
Also, like...
I actually learned...
I had to, like, learn a new way to pick up dad.
Because, like...
For long boys, there's actually, like...
Um...
There's, like, a specific way...
You have...
Not have to...
But it's, like...
Suggested.
You know?
To, like...
And how to pick them up.
Because they're so long.
I have to Google image this.
Because I was so fucking confused.
Because I was, like...
It's, like, how do I fucking...
Because, like...
Um...
It's more so of, like...
I guess, like...
As they get older...
For spying stuff.
Yeah, you have to hold...
Okay, so this is basically...
I have to Google this.
Because I was so confused.
Um...
Because, like...
How I usually carry them...
Is that...
Uh...
But this is...
This is it.
It's just so weird.
Like, you have to...
Grab their crotch.
And...
Because I...
I don't...
I have to...
I have to be, like...
How to pick up a wiener dog.
And then you have to, like...
Grab their crotch.
Yeah, and then, like...
Put the other hand...
Uh...
Underneath the chest.
The...
How to hold...
Your...
Um...
No, I...
I didn't pick him up.
Like...
I pick him up, like...
Oh, yeah.
How do I describe it?
Like...
Um...
I have two arms under...
But I...
I don't grab his...
To grab...
To pick up your wiener...
First off...
You gotta grab the wiener...
But, like...
Okay...
I...
I don't know how to explain how I pick...
Okay, so...
He's, like, on my arm in the end.
Like, he'll...
He rests his two legs...
On my arm.
Like, his front paws.
But, like...
I...
I never picked him up like that before.
So...
The wiener...
So I have to learn a new way...
I have to learn a new way...
To hold dad...
Because, like...
I wanted to be as...
Careful as possible...
Um...
I wanted to make sure that...
Uh...
I actually do not like it like that...
As a professional dog lifter...
Secure...
The wiener...
So...
Because it supports both ends...
But...
I do like...
But it's like...
My arm is, like...
On his rear legs...
Versus, like...
On his crouch...
Like...
That's how I used to hold him...
You know?
Because, you know...
Like, I don't know...
I...
I was just like...
I don't know...
I...
Like, you know...
In your head...
You don't think about...
Like that...
You know...
Like holding a dog...
Like that...
Yeah...
So I...
I had to learn a new way...
To like...
Pick him up...
Because I wanted to be sure...
He had as least...
As...
Um...
Little pressure...
As possible...
Um...
On his, like...
Neck and legs...
So...
Um...
So I had to...
Because like...
In the past...
Like...
Uh...
But when I got him back...
From...
The dog sitter...
After his back surgery...
He didn't need to be picked up anymore...
Um...
So like...
I didn't have to worry about that...
But like...
For now...
I actually have to pick him up and stuff...
And I got really worried...
I got scared...
Because I don't want to pick him up wrong...
That will put pressure on his front legs...
So I actually...
I was like...
Googling up like...
Proper techniques...
To pick up a...
To hold a wiener dog...
And...
And literally all of them was like...
They're like...
Or like...
Okay, this was the other way...
Um...
This was the other way...
But...
It's also very similar...
This is the other technique...
That I found...
I'll show you guys...
Uh...
Let's see...
It's a little small though...
So...
But...
This was the other way...
To hold them up...
So you...
You...
Cup the ass...
And...
The wiener meta...
So you...
You...
Basically...
The first off...
You start off the same...
But then your hand moves from the crouch...
To the ass...
Yes...
So...
To...
To the butt...
So like...
How to hold the shotgun...
It's so...
Yeah, you...
You...
Cup the cake...
So like...
It's a little...
The...
A different meta...
In terms of how...
Um...
How to hold it...
But apparently...
The other one...
The other one is more...
Um...
The other one supports the back...
The spine more...
Lock and load your wiener...
Dog...
Ha ha ha ha...
Ha ha ha...
Why he's so...
What...
I like...
Yeah, the shock...
The lock and load...
Shotgun...
Toe key...
Ha ha ha ha...
That's...
Yeah, as if you're holding a shotgun...
I mean...
It does look like you're holding a shotgun...
To be fair...
Uh...
Captain, welcome to the tomato fight...
Welcome, welcome...
Reload...
So...
But yeah, that is the...
Wiener dog meta...
Uh...
But also like...
Also...
Okay, I need to rant about this a little bit...
Uh...
Um...
But I'd be going to the bank yesterday...
And I was going to be like...
You know, I'm going to...
There was like...
I wanted...
There was like a dessert place...
A dessert coffee place...
Near my bank...
It's like...
You know what?
I'm going to reward myself...
I'm going to...
I'm going to reward myself for...
Walking...
10 minutes to the bank...
That long...
Hard walk...
Of 10 minutes...
You know...
So...
Um...
I was like...
There's a dessert place nearby...
So...
So strong and brave...
Doki...
Uh...
As the one does...
Oh...
Those...
10 long...
Minutes in the sun...
And outside...
Oh...
Good job, Doki...
You deserve a little treat...
Uh...
Such a strong woman...
Anyway...
But...
Um...
Oh my gosh...
I...
I think I forgot that...
Because I think university started for some people already...
And like the moment I went in...
It was literally just filled with...
I think college students on their fucking...
MacBooks...
Just...
Taking every chair and table...
Because I...
I don't...
I just wanted to...
Eat like a little dessert...
On a table...
And it was literally...
Every table was just filled with students...
On their fucking MacBooks...
Uh...
I was like...
Where can I sit...
A paying customer...
And I'm joking...
I'm just...
I...
I'm joking...
They deserve to be there, okay?
They deserve.
But all I'm saying is that I, a paid customer, who wouldn't loiter longer than they're supposed to be!
I can't believe it, Doki hates education.
Damn kids!
But anyway, I was just, I was mad.
Because I was like, I worked so hard, walking this 10 minutes to the bank.
And all I wanted to do was sit at a table for maybe 20 to 30 minutes.
Maybe 20 to 30 minutes eating something that, eating a dessert and coffee as well.
But yeah, I was just like, I was just like, oh my gosh, it was just all MacBooks.
I'm surprised people, I guess it's more efficient.
I don't know, when I, I mean I used a MacBook too, in university.
But I only did it because it was like, everyone else was doing it, in a way.
Like, you know how like, peer pressure?
And like, my parents were like, you need a MacBook for this.
Um, you need a MacBook if you're gonna be taking notes and stuff.
Um, and uh, no, I was a Mac, I used a MacBook.
A Mac, uh, or just a Mac, I don't know.
I felt like it was just like, it was just like a thing to do in university.
Like, it didn't matter if it's like better or worse.
Like, every student just had a Mac.
For some fucking reason.
Um, um, but yeah.
Anyway, I was sad I couldn't get my, couldn't get my, my dessert and coffee.
So I got the second, the worst thing, Timbits.
Ha ha ha ha!
Out of Tim Hortons.
And an ice cap.
That was so sad.
I was like, if I'm gonna walk and eat, I might as well just go to Tim Hortons.
Ha ha ha ha!
For the real walking and eating vibe.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Ha ha ha ha!
I'm, I'm just, I'm just like, you know, I'm not, cause like, I wanted to get like, something nice and fancy.
At like, in a coffee shop.
But then I was just like, okay, if I'm gonna be walking, walking and eating, I might as well get Tim Hortons.
For the, that's the real walking, uh, walking dessert.
Um, Ellie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I feel like I need to let you know.
My internet cut out and all I was able to hear was Google how to hold your wiener.
Thanks internet.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, I, to me this is like, like, for those who don't know what Tim Hortons are, it's basically like, what, it's, it's like, I would, it's, it's cheap.
But it could be cheaper.
Cause like, the coffee's terrible.
Um, and like, the coffee is just like, it's so watered down.
The coffee is so bad.
No, it's, it doesn't even deserve to be called Starbucks.
Cause at least like, Starbucks has like, actual like, drinks and stuff.
But like, oh my gosh, it's, it's a Canadian Duncans.
I think, yeah, Canadian, it's basically Canadian Duncans, but a, a tier lower than that.
The only good thing from Tim Hortons is literally the ice cap.
Yeah, because in like, Timbits, you just like, feel like shit.
Like, if you, if you just feel like shit, just Timbits.
And, um, and, um, but the only good thing is like, are like, ice caps, which is like, ice cappuccinos.
But, the only reason why it's good is because they overload it with so much fucking sugar.
And caffeine is the only reason why it's good.
It's, there's just so much fucking sugar.
Hehehehehehe in it.
Um, um, but Timbits are alright.
As long as they have like, a good selection of Timbits.
For those who don't know what Timbits are, they're basically, um, donut holes.
Like, you know, like, you know, we're like, where do the holes go in the donuts?
That's, that's basically the Timbits.
They're the little donut holes, um, that they make.
Um, and they're pretty good.
And also, you feel like absolute shit.
Hehehehe.
You grab a Timbit.
AKZ, thank you for the, uh, five gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, it varies by location.
I mean, that's all franchises though.
Uh, because I, uh, for those who don't know how franchises work.
Um, um, franchises are basically like, um, simple business stuff.
Uh, business lessons to all you guys.
But, anyone can start a franchise.
So, you just gotta apply for it.
Like, you know, apply from the main company.
And then, like, they just send you all the, they just send you like, the ingredients.
The food.
Um, like the uniforms, the pamphlets and everything.
But you pick like, the location.
And like, how it's run.
So, and spend the money.
They just send you like, the equipment and stuff.
Yeah, so they're owned locally.
And they just license it.
It's like an IP.
They just license it.
I, I can technically, I can technically like, buy a Tim Hortons right now.
Yeah, you have to, yeah.
And you buy the supplies from them.
Like, technically, I can run, uh, Tim Hortons right now.
And be like, hey, this is my Tim Hortons.
Can you guys go support me?
Like, anyone can do it.
Please don't, please don't buy a Tim Hortons.
Please don't buy a franchise, Toki.
Anyway, uh, but yeah.
So that's how franchises work.
So it depends on, basically depends on like, uh, um, like, you know, who's running it.
So if there's a, if you're like, oh, I went to this plate, this fast food place.
Um, and like, it was terrible.
Um, I'm never going to any other fast food place like this again.
It just, it usually might just be like, whoever was running that one.
Um, cause like, they're the ones that's in charge of it, not the actual company itself.
Um, I actually, it's also like, why, I know like, I heard like, stories about how like, McDonald's ice cream machines are always broken, um, in the past.
But they recently fixed that issue.
But the reason why McDonald's ice cream places were always broken, was because they can only buy the equipment to make McDonald's ice cream from this one company.
And only this one company can fix the McDonald's ice cream machines.
So, you can't like, outsource it to any other like, place to fix it.
It's only, you can only like, hire the company itself to fix the ice cream machine.
And I was like that, yeah, the monopoly is fucking crazy.
Cause it's like, um, part of the contract and the license and everything.
So, they recently fixed that.
So now, now, now, ice cream, the ice cream machine can be fixed by, um, by any company you want now.
I don't know what, maybe they paid them like, I don't know, billions of dollars to be like, stop that.
Cause like, they're like, stop, you're actually like, hurting our business.
I don't know what the contract they did.
But, now it's different.
Now you can like, fix it.
You can hire anyone to fix it now.
Yeah, oh yeah.
I mean, I won't be surprised if it became a lawsuit.
It's really, really like, whoever has the better lawyer.
Uh, next thing, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I can feel your manager's fear from here.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Okay, even the employees can now, uh, repair it too.
Uh, oh yeah, speaking of like, dogs earlier.
I was watching a YouTube shorts of like, this lady feeding their fucking Doberman.
And like, I did not realize how much big dogs have to eat.
To like, be healthy and like, satisfied.
Because I've owned small dogs my entire life.
And by small dogs, I mean I've owned wiener dogs my entire life.
So like, yeah, so I was watching this lady literally like...
Like, I know, it's like, not even like, a big thick dog.
It was like a...
It was just like, I guess like an extra...
I guess he was...
I guess the Doberman was like, super fit.
Um, but...
Um...
Um, I was like, watching her feed the Doberman.
And she was like, plastering it with like, five different kinds of meat.
And then like, and then like, a fucking crocodile's foot.
Because she was like, oh yeah, she...
My, my Doberman loves crunchy food.
And I was like, what?
I was like...
They can, they can do that?
I was so...
Like...
Okay, I'll show you guys the video.
I was watching it.
I was like, holy fuck.
I was like, oh my god.
This dog can fucking eat.
Um...
Did I like it?
Oh, here you go.
Duck crunch.
Here we go.
You know what?
I'll let you guys hear the video too.
Fuck it.
Haha.
Um...
Here.
I'm not gonna show it because I have to...
Actually, yeah.
I have to like, redo my, my, um...
My OBS stuff to show it.
ACP themed dinner.
She still loves her DJ goal.
Unless you're gently choosing this one.
You guys loved it when I used this bowl last time.
Want to show you guys that you can remove this meal section if you don't want to use the sofita part.
For the base, we'll be using this pork and duck dinner.
I would've done a fish base.
Like, that's so much.
Honestly, if you'd like her raw base to be fish.
The important part of these dinners is that she enjoys her meal.
So, I'll be sticking to things that she likes.
Next, I have two options for wet food.
First one is this herring and mackerel.
That's the rich person's dog diet.
If you like a piece of water texture, definitely go with the rustic stew.
Right now, I need something a bit thicker.
And you guys will see why.
I'm trying to make this, like, barrier.
I purposely left this section blank because I want to add, like, the ocean.
Hopefully this works.
And then she puts that goat milk and stuff.
And then, like, there's...
You know what I do for dad?
I open a can of wet food and I pour half of it.
Yes!
This dog gets stripped!
Why is the milk blue?
Because it's goat milk.
This is my first video with this bowl.
You know that the hardest part for her are these drawers.
So to really motivate her, I'll be putting in some sweet dried mackerel.
This is every dinner, too.
The last one I'm adding is this air-dried salmon head.
Like, bro, it's a fucking salmon head as an extra crunch!
Here is the final result.
Look at this up close.
Aries is still ready for her meal.
She's already standing right beside me.
It has to go through inspection, but I think this one is a no-brainer.
I hope you guys enjoyed.
Here's your video.
Why is goat milk blue?
Like, I was like, holy shit!
Look at him!
He just eats it!
Oh!
Everything, too!
And then, like, she gives her...
I was, like, watching some of her videos, too, because I was, like, super cute.
I was like, do you do this every day?
Like...
I was like, do you do this every fucking day?
And then, like, in one of the videos, she was like, oh, yeah.
Um, sometimes I give her, like, cow ear as a treat, because she loves it.
And I was like, you can give dogs cow ears?
Like, I was like, what?
That's...
Dogs eat that?
Like...
Yeah!
I was like, holy fuck!
What?!
Like, there's, like, special dog treats where the dog's snack is literally a fucking cow's ear.
Um, and then, like, Dad, just, like, like, open a half...
I'm open a can of wet dog food, beef and vegetable stew.
I pour half of it, and then I'm like, here you go!
And you know what his treat is?
Those little green dental treats for his teeth.
I'll be like, use your green dental treat, and that's good enough for him.
That's...
He's happy with that.
Yeah.
Yeah, the greenies.
Poor...
What do you mean?
Poor Dad!
He doesn't know any better!
Bro, I'm...
I just...
I didn't know, like, big dogs.
Like...
I didn't realize big dogs have to eat so much.
I...
It just, like, blew my mind when I was, like, watching that video.
I was like, oh my god, that's a whole nother...
He cannot watch this video.
He must not know the secrets.
He...
It's like, he doesn't have to know that his life could be better.
He doesn't...
Millie, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome.
Poor dog thinks he...
He doesn't have to know.
He doesn't have to know about the greener pastures in life.
Keep him ignorant.
Yes.
That's why he's in the prison.
Um...
Uh...
Marco, thank you for the...
Super chat, thank you, thank you.
If you were to go on a grand bank heist, who would you bring to help?
And who would you be the getaway driver?
I was going to the bank heist.
Like...
Why do that when I just...
Why make that hard for myself when I could just...
When I could...
When I could just...
Do a rug pull...
On crypto...
I'm just thinking like...
Bro, why would I make that so hard for myself?
I'll just...
Fucking...
I'll just start a cryptocurrency...
Or an NFT...
I'll just say it...
Then like...
Cause like...
Okay, if you do a bank heist...
You're already like...
You know...
You're already in danger of the law.
You know?
So like...
Don't keep going...
Dropping soon, boys.
Not a rug pull, by the way.
Like...
I'm just saying like...
If...
I guess like...
You do the bank heist just for the thrill of it.
Like...
Just for the adrenaline.
Cause like...
If you're gonna do a bank heist...
You're...
You're gonna have...
You know...
Um...
The...
Like...
Build...
I mean...
I guess I could wear a mask and stuff.
And then like...
Not get caught and everything.
I mean like...
I could just change skin suit.
But then I'm just like...
Yeah, but then like...
Thing is...
You'll have to have that...
Cause the money is...
So...
The hardest part about...
Doki, why do you know so much?
Okay, look.
I watched a lot about these...
Like...
Heist movies, okay?
And like...
And also like...
Read about it.
So...
The thing about robbing a bank...
The money is marked.
And there's also like...
Died and stuff on the money.
So...
You can't just like...
You know...
Spend that money at supermarkets...
Or stuff like that.
Because like...
You know...
Spend it at a supermarket...
Or just buy it...
Like at a store or anything.
Because they...
They would...
Um...
Put the money...
They would monitor...
Where the money is going.
So...
To do that...
You have to like...
Uh...
Make sure...
That you can...
You're connected with someone...
Who can move the money...
Uh...
And...
Yeah, they'll just trace the serial number.
So you have to...
Go underground...
Within like...
You know...
The black market...
To be able to...
Move the money...
Safely...
Underground...
Where they can't trace it.
And it's not like...
Fully marked...
You have to launder it...
And everything.
And that's a whole different thing.
Like...
Money laundering...
Is already like...
So much work...
In general...
As well.
I mean...
You think the hardest part...
Is doing a bank heist...
But the hardest part...
Is trying to launder the money...
To make sure...
It doesn't connect it back...
To you.
Um...
Because you...
And like...
With that...
The safest way to launder money...
Is to open like...
A business...
And stuff...
To launder it...
But like...
Then you have to go into...
Doing...
Um...
Then you have to...
Go like...
Um...
And like...
You know...
Look...
Scout out for...
Small businesses...
That you can buy...
So you can start...
Laundering it...
And even...
And that's where...
Tim Hortons comes along...
That...
And that's where...
Tim Hortons come along...
Where I would start...
You open my own...
Tim Hortons...
So I can launder the money...
For my...
Bank heist...
Uh...
But anyway...
But like...
Why do all of that...
When I can just start...
A cryptocurrency...
And just...
Rug pull...
Or even...
Just an NFT...
Because...
Starting a cryptocurrency...
I just...
I can just...
I just be like...
Hey guys...
Invest in this cryptocurrency...
Like...
I swear to god...
It's not a rug pull...
And then...
And then to...
To pretend that everything is okay...
I can get my family and friends...
Um...
To like...
Invest in the cryptocurrency...
Beforehand...
So it looks like...
There's a lot of money...
Um...
To get...
Like...
It's going...
It's a good cryptocurrency and stuff...
So it looks like...
Um...
It looks like...
There's high value in it...
Because...
The...
The value of it...
Like...
It started off low...
And then I'll be like...
I'll be like...
To my family and friends...
Like...
Okay...
Start buying the coins...
Right now...
And then...
It shots up...
And then we all just sell it...
And we all just sell it...
And then we all have money...
And that's like...
And then like...
If we look at Logan Paul...
Clearly...
There's no consequences...
For their actions...
So...
Umm...
Sorry...
Allegedly...
If you look at...
Logan Paul...
It seems to be working...
Also that...
Hawktuo Girl too...
Who started a...
Fucking cryptocurrency.
And then, like...
And that, like... I don't even know.
Like, basically destroyed the career that she was...
She managed to build.
Off of Hot Toa.
Like, surprisingly...
Cryptocurrency is what destroyed her career.
Which is already saying something.
That she could build a career.
Off of the Hot Toa thing.
But...
Um...
At least she made...
Like, I'm pretty sure she made so much money.
From just her...
The cryptocurrency alone.
That she didn't have to, like...
Like, she doesn't care at that point.
Because she knew that meme was gonna die.
Like, very...
Like, it was gonna die, like...
Eventually.
Or very soon.
So, like...
I felt like the cryptocurrency thing was, like...
Her last thing.
Like, her last cash out.
Before...
Before, um...
Before, like...
The meme fully dies.
Um...
Uh...
Though she has lost a lot of money.
How did...
How did she lose a lot of money?
She had so many brand deals.
Like...
She...
Yeah, she sold her...
Damn, I was gonna say!
She even sold her...
She sold her Twitter?
That's crazy.
That's when you're like...
Like, she knew it was over.
Like...
She knew it was fucking over.
Anyway...
Um...
But also, that reminded me of...
That kid...
Okay, I don't know if you guys heard of the story.
But...
There was this...
Kid...
That...
Um...
That would...
Would always do, like, rug pull...
Cryptocurrencies.
And then, like...
And then people kept falling for it.
Like...
Every time.
He even named the currency, like...
Rug pull...
Like...
He even named the currency, like...
Rug pull or some shit.
And...
Um...
Yeah, he was like some 14 year old kid.
14 to 15 year old kid.
And he ran three...
Back to back...
Rug pull...
Cryptocurrencies.
And...
And like...
And then like...
The same people...
Kept investing on it.
Yeah.
And like...
He's like...
I...
They just kept doing it.
Like...
Good for him.
They'll never see it coming.
And apparently they didn't!
They...
Apparently they didn't.
But yeah, like I was saying...
Um...
Yeah.
It's like...
Is it really the kids fault if they kept falling for it?
Like...
Fell for it again.
Over...
Award.
Um...
But like I was saying...
Like...
Why would I...
Why would I rob a bank...
When I can...
And I feel like people don't rob banks anymore.
Like...
It's just like...
People just don't rob banks anymore.
It's just not worth it in the end.
The...
The amount of...
Effort and planning you have to do...
To rob a bank...
For the...
Payout for it...
It's just like...
It's a lost...
It is a lost art form.
Yeah, it's hard to do it now too.
Like the work for it.
Like why do that?
That...
Why do that illegally?
When you can legally...
Uh...
Pull off scams online.
Like...
Because like...
There's no laws for...
Crypto...
There's no laws for cryptocurrency...
Batman...
Yet...
There's no...
Because that's the whole point...
Of cryptocurrency...
That it's not regulated...
By...
The banks...
Or the government...
So...
There's no laws for cryptocurrency...
Batman...
So...
It's...
No joker...
That's a rug full joker...
Stop!
Um...
There's like...
Like...
There are laws...
But you know what I mean?
It's like...
The government doesn't really know...
What to do...
With cryptocurrency...
Because it's such a...
It's like...
You know...
It's...
It's not regulated at all...
Um...
By...
Uh...
Um...
By like...
Like any like...
Actual formal structure...
And...
Um...
Because of that...
It's like...
Easier...
To like...
Legally scam people...
So like...
All I'm saying is...
We're smarter...
Not harder...
I mean...
But...
It is sad that...
You know...
We don't get to have...
Getaway drivers anymore...
Um...
There's no...
Thrill of...
Robbing people...
Anymore...
Ha ha ha ha ha...
I...
I know...
We lost the thrill...
Of robbing people...
I know...
Isn't that sad?
We don't...
Ha ha ha ha...
My...
Dubinetiver told me...
The blockchain...
Took the big robbers job...
No...
More...
Baby driver...
Ha ha ha...
Scamming people online just don't do it for me.
Back in my day, we scammed people in real life.
I can't... AI has truly hurt the economy, guys.
AI has ruined everything, guys.
We can't even, like...
We can't even wear funny masks and rob people at gunpoint anymore.
Crypto Bro has killed the bank robber.
We truly live in the scam society.
Um... She's not... Guys, I'm not promoting.
All I'm saying, like, unless it's Bitcoin, I don't believe...
I personally don't really... I don't know.
It's, like, it's hard to tell.
Because I know there's, like, people that actually made, like, millions...
Like, I don't know no people.
You know, oh my gosh, I know this guy who does, like...
No, I don't.
I actually... I don't know any people, like, personally.
But I've seen people...
Um... I've seen people, like...
Um... become, like, millionaires just from, like, investing in cryptocurrency.
But also losing a lot of money investing in cryptocurrency.
So it's, like, it's just, like, the stock market, essentially.
It's, like, a huge fucking gamble.
Um...
It's an incredible... Like, like, everything.
Like, it's just a huge gamble investing in things.
Yeah, it's just gambling.
It's...
It's basically gambling because you don't really know, like, what's gonna go well and what...
Um...
What's gonna, like, you know, not do so well.
It's just, yeah.
And...
But, you know what's...
What's not a scam?
The Doki coin that I'm gonna drop...
That is not...
That's...
100% not a rug pull.
Uh...
The odds are...
Are, like, actually, like, 90...
90 to 10.
In terms of 10, not of it.
10% being a rug pull and 90% of it not being a rug pull.
Uh...
So to the moon we go.
A genuine collector's item.
Chat.
I've got it.
And, by the way, guys, I'm planning on opening a Tim Hortons soon, too.
Uh...
Is that the one...
Yeah, at 1 million subscribers, I will...
I will make Doki coin a reality, chat.
Um...
Quell, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If there's something with Doki bread on it, there will be a Dragoon who will buy it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Please don't, please don't open DokiCoin.
Yeah, that's the, that's the 1 million subscribers, um, announcement.
Out of a million subscribers, DokiCoin will be real.
Um, investing all my money in DokiCoin right now!
Yeah, I mean, it is interesting.
It is interesting, like, I feel like NFTs are dead-dead for real.
That NFT was such a fucking fad.
Like, they're like, oh my god, it's like a PNG that only you can own.
Please don't copy it.
I remember like, I remember when people were like, stop saving my, my NFT!
It's, it's mine!
Oh, and then what's his name?
Um, the guy who voices, the guy who does Robot Chicken.
Um, oh my god, what the fuck was his name?
The guy that does Robot Chicken.
Seth, what's his name?
No.
It was a Seth, uh...
Control C, right click, save.
Seth Green!
I remember I talked about it before when Seth Green started his own NFT show.
But like, he couldn't, he couldn't broadcast it at all because his NFT got held hostage by some, like, by some NFT bro.
And, yeah, Seth Green was like, a heavy investor.
And, um...
And, what's it called?
The Ape one?
Oh my gosh, I already forgot.
I feel like, a year on the internet is literally 20 years.
I already forgot, like, what...
Oh, his Bored Ape.
Yeah, oh my god, the Bored Ape thing.
By the way, guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but Bored Ape was started in...
Four years ago.
In...
In four years, Bored Ape has already fell off.
Like...
TikTok.
I'm surprised I'm still here.
I'm surprised I'm still here, guys.
But in four years, Bored Ape has already been, like, forgotten.
Like, I also, like, forgot, like, what they were called.
Um...
But...
Seth Green was gonna start a comedy show based off of, like, all the NFTs that...
Yeah, I outlived the apes.
Isn't that crazy?
I actually outlived the Bored Ape era.
But...
Um...
But Seth Green, um...
Was...
Had a pilot show that's based off of his NFTs.
But he couldn't release it because his account got hacked.
And then, like, one of the Bored Apes that was supposed to be, like, part of his show...
Um...
Got sold off to another NFT collector.
And then that collector was holding the Ape hostage.
And was like, you have to transfer this X amount of money if you want your Ape back.
And...
So...
Yeah.
So, like...
Seth Green couldn't get his Bored Ape show, like, greenlit because of his fucking NFT getting held hostage.
Which was just...
Which was, like, crazy.
And then I think by the time he got his show...
Like, his NFT back...
Um...
The show got, like...
They...
They canceled the show.
The guy did...
Did Seth a favor.
Couldn't he just make...
Yeah, but...
You don't understand.
It was his NFT.
It was, like, his main character in the show.
Um...
Oh, and I remember there was that time...
When the...
The Bored Ape or Yacht Club or whatever...
They did, like, a convention or, like, a party for...
They did, like, a convention or party for, like, every member...
Like, for members who had a Bored Ape.
And then, like, at the...
At the party...
Uh...
Oh, yeah.
Ape Fest.
For those who don't know...
There was the infamous laser...
Laser incident...
Where...
They got UV lights...
But their UV lights...
Were...
Um...
Were, like, used...
To, like...
Kill...
Parasites or something?
They basically got very unsafe UV lights, where it was nearly, like, burning the people there.
Yeah, they got industrial UV lights instead of, like, concert UV lights.
So, like, apparently, there were reports that...
There was one report where one guy was, like, blind for, like, several days because he was staring at the UV lights.
And, like, people had, like, actual, like, burn...
Like, yeah, it was, like, unfiltered UV lights.
And someone had, like, burn marks and stuff on their skins because of it.
And I was like, how do you fuck up that?
Like, I don't know how that...
Like, I don't know.
When you buy UV lights, I'm just, like...
I'm...
Did they order it off Amazon?
Like, how did no one warn them?
I was so confused.
I was like, how does that...
How does that get unnoticed?
You know?
Like, how did, like, no one notice that?
Or, like, no one stop them?
Like, was it ordered off Amazon?
Like...
Because I feel like you're buying industrial UV lights.
There's, like...
I don't know.
Even reading that on a...
Like, if you're, like, I need...
I need UV lights for a concert.
You know?
For a party.
And then you read the description.
And it says, Industrial UV lights.
And, like...
I don't know.
Maybe their first thought was that...
Wow.
Industrial means, like...
Means that it's stronger.
So, it'll look cooler.
Like...
I guess that was the...
I guess that was the mindset.
This industrial equals cooler.
Because, um...
It's stronger.
And looks better at night.
Bigger equals better.
Like, that's how I'm thinking it.
That's how it's, like...
Because I'm like, Why didn't anyone stop?
Because I got...
That's what, like, makes me so confused.
Like, we're doing no...
We're already called...
You know how, like...
Okay.
This is a...
I was getting this.
Okay.
You know how, like...
You know...
Um...
Fail-safes?
Wouldn't there be, like...
What's that word called?
Where a person would be there to make sure, like...
Things...
Go according to plan.
And nothing fucks up.
There's, like, a thing for that.
I don't remember what...
Adults?
Not true.
Uh...
Um...
Safeguards.
Regulations.
Like, someone to make sure something doesn't fuck up.
You know?
Oh shit.
No.
I guess, like...
Fels...
Like...
I guess, like...
I don't know.
I guess, like, quality control.
Like, someone there to, like, make sure, like...
Things don't fuck up.
So I'm just, like...
How...
I guess they paid people off, too.
Because I know, like...
Some people do that.
Where they're, like...
Um...
They're, like...
Oh...
There seems to be something wrong here.
And they'll be, like...
No, there isn't.
Here's 500...
Here's a board ape.
Like...
No, there isn't anything wrong.
Here's a board ape for your time, sir.
And they're, like...
Okay.
So...
Um...
That's how I'm, like, thinking.
Because I'm, like...
How did that...
By...
Bypass everything?
How did they...
How did industrial UV lights manage to fucking get there?
But...
No, I think...
I think it's crazy.
But I'm glad, like...
NFTs have, like...
Died out.
I think...
That reminded me of that...
What was it?
The FNAF clone?
It was that FNAF clone where...
Oh, yeah.
Before I go on to the NFT...
I love how the reason why we'll never get a...
Actual, like...
FNAF franchise...
Is because...
Um...
Scott is so scared that someone is gonna...
Copycat...
The Bite of 75...
In real life.
So that's why we will never get an IRL, like...
Five Nights at Freddy's franchise.
Or, like, just, like, a pizzeria...
Type thing for, like...
Um...
Tourists.
Or, like...
For, like, a...
You know, like, a touristy gimmick place.
Um...
But...
Scott was actually...
Is actually, like...
Super scared that someone's gonna recreate...
The Bite of 69...
In real life.
Because of it.
Um...
Yeah.
That's why we'll never get a pizzeria.
Um...
Fake Markiplier fan...
Doesn't even know the bite quote.
I know the bite quote.
It's the Bite of 45.
Um...
Anyway.
As I was saying...
Uh...
There was that...
I don't remember if people remember it...
But there was this, like...
There was this, like...
Five Nights at Freddy's clone...
Where it's based off of, like...
Um...
A candy store.
And...
Um...
It was based off a candy store.
And everybody was super fucking hyped.
Because...
They're like...
Oh my god!
That looks so good!
The graphics and the concepts...
And the...
Um...
And the trailer.
And then in the end...
It was just an NFT.
He had the Candy Land NFT!
Yeah!
And then they're like...
Don't worry guys!
We're actually gonna make a game!
And then later on...
They're like...
Sorry!
I meant we're gonna have an animation!
And apparently the animation...
Is like...
Is it like...
Half AI or something?
I don't remember.
I watched a little bit of it.
Because I got curious.
I was like...
What the fuck is going on?
It looks so bad.
It actually had promise too.
Which was funny.
It actually looked like...
It could be good.
But...
Um...
But obviously like...
It was...
Yeah, it was...
It was like...
Half AI generated or something.
It had so much potential.
And then they're like...
JK!
We're just gonna sell NFTs now.
Um...
Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll be mad if I got a Bored Ape for a bribe.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also...
Speaking of like...
Sorry, this whole thing is about cryptocurrency and...
And NFTs.
But I find it super interesting.
Because it is a...
New concept in society.
So every...
It feels like every month...
There's something new going on about it.
Because everyone's still trying to figure out...
How the fuck cryptocurrency and NFTs work.
But like...
Apparently...
There is a...
There is one person...
Who owns...
The majority of Bitcoin right now.
But he hasn't touched his account...
Before like...
How many...
Like 10 plus years or some shit.
And everyone...
So like...
Yeah, so basically...
This guy...
Technically...
If he ever...
Gets access...
To...
Yeah, the wallet that's...
Lost forever.
Uh...
So...
No one knows...
What happened to this man.
Because...
His Bitcoin...
Has like...
Not been touched...
Since...
It's founding.
Yeah...
It's like...
The one piece is real.
And like...
He basically...
Holds...
Majority...
Of like...
The...
The value of Bitcoin.
So if he...
Yeah...
Everyone...
People are like...
What...
Don't know...
If it's because...
He lost...
The...
It's literally the gold mine of Bitcoin.
But...
The moment...
Anyone...
Has access...
Um...
To...
His wallet...
And sell...
All the Bitcoin...
That's in that wallet...
It will crash...
The Bitcoin economy.
The person...
Who sold it...
Will be rich...
For the rest of his life.
Like...
He's made it for his generation...
And the generation...
For like...
Maybe like...
10 generation...
They'll...
They'll be okay.
But like...
Whoever...
Actually has...
Gets access...
To that account...
And sells...
All of that Bitcoin...
The Bitcoin economy...
Will crash...
Ha ha ha ha...
Ha ha ha...
Which is...
So it...
Like...
I find that incredibly interesting...
Because...
The biggest rug...
Full of all time...
Um...
So...
It all lies...
In...
One man...
Like...
One man's wallet...
Yeah...
Ha ha ha...
Nobody knows...
The man...
This man is the main...
Because the money...
Hasn't been touched...
In...
Since the founding of Bitcoin...
So, it all relies on this one guy.
Yeah.
So, like, some people say he's dead, because no one knows.
No one knows who he really is.
Like, people say he's either dead, or, like, he forgot his password.
But this... that wallet is what is the deciding factor of, like, what Bitcoin is worth right now.
Sounds like the guy who threw away his PC with his Bitcoin account.
Saw Bitcoin go up and desperately searched a bunch of landfills for it.
He is... he is the one.
And I hear, like, people have been trying to hack in...
Like, I think, like, people have been trying to hack into his Bitcoin wallet, but it's been, like...
Like, nobody can access it.
Let's see, let me see if I can find his worth right now.
I don't even know how much Bitcoin he has.
It's actually crazy.
It's like...
I don't remember.
It was so much.
I have, like...
It has to be, like, fucking millions.
We're gonna steal a...
National Treasure 3.
We're gonna steal the Bitcoin wallet.
One coin to rule them all.
After dark.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki Doki has the best laugh.
A bundle of joy.
Period.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, that wallet has, like, never been touched to.
Um...
It was over 300 million.
Jesus Christ.
Uh...
What else I wanted to talk to you guys about?
Buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh.
I wrote some stuff down.
Um...
Buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh.
Uh...
Or, like...
Save some tweets.
My guy...
The one Bitcoin to rule them up.
Buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh.
Oh, yeah.
Funny thing.
Um...
Okay, so...
You might notice that I'm starting to tweet a little bit more, too.
Um...
But, basically, like...
Uh, for a... almost a year.
This was out of sheer laziness, by the way.
There was no other reason I did this other than the fact that I was really fucking lazy.
But, if you have Twitter Blue, um, you know how Twitter Blue has... or like, Premium, sorry.
They always change the name that I keep forgetting what they're called these days.
But, Twitter Premium.
So you know how there was like this monetization thing that they did?
Um, so, like, you get paid for your tweets and stuff.
So, I had... so, um...
At first, uh, they... I'm not farming interactions, guys.
I'm not trying...
Oh no, it was just the fact that, um, so, basically, um...
If I was truly farming interactions, I would... I would tweet stuff like, name a VTuber.
I bet you can't name a VTuber who's, uh, um...
Whose letter doesn't start with a vowel, guys.
That's farming interactions.
Oh my gosh, the amount of people that fall into that.
Or be like, ooh, what's your current favorite starter in all the Pokemon...
In all the Pokemon gens, what's your favorite starter?
Um...
Um... Or like, reply with your favorite starter.
Or, um...
Uh, anyway...
Anyway!
Um...
So...
At first, Twitter...
When it was first, Twitter Blue, you didn't have...
Uh, you can just buy it, and then you get the monetization thing.
Uh, by subscribe...
Like, by just subscribing to Twitter Blue, you automatically get the...
The monetization of your tweets and getting paid to tweet and stuff.
So...
Uh...
Or like...
Quote retweet with...
Okay...
This might be a little bit of a hot take, but those that...
Share a piece of lore about yourself...
They're very interesting.
The person that fucking first came up with that...
Was 100% interaction farming.
Like...
And all the iterations of that...
That is like, peak interaction farming right there.
That...
But like, it's interesting.
At least you get something interesting out of that, though.
You know?
Like, actual, like, substance to your tweets.
Um...
Yeah...
Anyway...
Um...
It's an interaction goldman.
But, what I'm trying to say is that...
Uh...
B-b-b-b-b-ba-b-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-wa What I was trying to say,...
Um...
Was that...
When Twitter Blue first came out...
You didn't have to verify your fucking ID.
So...
If you guys didn't know about Twitter Blue...
Oh my gosh, I didn't even realize that.
Uh...
But for Twitter Blue... Sorry, I was like, for some reason, I was like, I don't know why I was like, all the way over here.
And I was like, get away from me.
But, um...
You don't have to verify your identity or anything, so...
But when you get Twitter Blue, you actually have to, like...
send them a picture of your ID and your passport and stuff like that.
And then, like, link an account, like, link some fucking account.
So, I didn't do that for an entire year, because I was very lazy.
And also, like, I don't know, I didn't really...
At that time, I was like, I don't really want to give them my data.
Like, I didn't...
Yeah, I was like, I don't know.
But then, like...
But then, um...
Um, I did that.
I linked...
I sent them a picture.
You know, I sent them a picture of my ID and stuff.
Um...
My ID, like...
Last month or some shit.
Or, like...
Yeah, last month.
Um...
Because I was like, everybody has my...
You know, every tech company has my information now.
Like, at that point...
You know, you're like...
I feel like...
At that point, I was like, I think Elon Musk already knows who I am.
Like, at that point, like...
It's just basically, like...
Does it really matter?
I'm pretty sure he already has that information already.
So...
He's literally...
Okay, it's a little scary to think about.
But, um...
He is the...
He's gonna be, like, the first...
He's gonna be the...
He's, like...
He's heading towards becoming the richest man in the world.
You know?
That's, like, the scary thought.
And then, at that point, I was like, you know what?
Like, I'm pretty sure he already has it.
So, that's why I was like, oh, why am I...
What the fuck?
I might as well...
I might as well just actually get my...
The monetization back.
And...
And because of that...
Because...
Don't...
The...
Why I was, like, thinking about getting my monetization back...
Was because, literally, the monetization thing...
Pays for my Twitter premium.
So...
It's just, like...
I...
Technically, it's just free premium.
You know?
That's why I was like, okay, I should...
I should tweet a little bit more.
Because, so, at least, like, if I don't have...
Technically, like...
They're not getting...
They're losing money by me...
Buying premium.
So, like, it's...
Like, you're already, like, what?
A quad...
I don't even remember.
He was like, what?
He's like, eh...
What's his word again?
Where...
The amount of wealth he's gonna be.
Like, for being the richest man in the world.
Oh, yeah.
True linear or whatever.
True linear.
And I was just like...
Bro, like...
I'm just thinking, like...
Um...
Yeah, he's literally...
He's giving me money...
To have Twitter premium.
So, I was like, might as well.
You know?
The more I tweet, the more...
The more he's...
Paying me.
Instead of me buying Twitter premium.
Uh...
Maxi...
Yakov...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
After...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Joki...
Oh, I already read that.
But think again.
So, you buy premium to take money.
Well, I buy premium...
To have free premium.
I know it's like...
Really...
It's...
It's so weird.
I...
I know.
It's like...
It's such a weird method.
You get premium just so that you can have it for free.
Uh...
Because like...
The amount I make monthly off of Twitter premium...
Is...
Um...
The amount...
Like...
It pays off for Twitter premium.
If not, like...
I get more than what I pay for.
So technically, it's free premium plus extra money.
Yeah.
It pays...
Basically, it pays for itself.
And I like Twitter premium because...
Um...
I get to edit my tweets.
Like, Twitter premium isn't for anyone, buddy.
Everybody.
But for me, it's just...
I just like the fact that I can edit tweets.
And I can post longer videos.
That's really it.
Um...
And as a content creator...
I feel like you sort of need that.
You know?
Like...
Yeah.
It's an infinite money glitch.
I'm literally getting free money from Twitter.
Uh...
Yeah.
And I don't get ads too.
Which is nice.
You're probably making bank off this week.
Dot quote.
I don't know.
Um...
How much is Twitter premium?
I don't have the extra Twitter premium where I can have Grok become an anime girl.
Sorry.
I don't have Grok premium plus or whatever.
I was so surprised that existed.
I was like, people pay for Grok plus?
Like...
Grok plus exists?
Like, so you can have your AI wear a fucking lingerie?
Oh my god.
Maybe I should pay for that.
Like...
But...
Um...
How much...
How much is...
How much is the...
Okay.
What am I at?
I'm subscribed to...
Uh...
What am I at?
I don't even remember.
Uh...
Am I at X Pro?
No.
Am I?
I don't know.
What's X Pro?
I just clicked X Pro.
Open display.
Oh!
So you can have a little Twitter deck thing.
Uh...
Um...
It's not even that well made.
Look...
People just want...
People...
Oh, let me say...
I think...
Basically, like...
As long as there is a hot anime woman in lingerie...
I don't...
For those...
Like...
I think, like, the feature for the extra Grok was literally just...
Hot anime woman in lingerie.
Like...
I don't think they're looking for anything else after...
I don't think...
I don't think they're, like, looking for more than that.
If that was the feature.
Uh...
I don't think they, like, want more.
As long as it provides that...
I think they're happy.
I don't even know which...
One I...
Which one I subscribe to in premium.
Does it tell you?
I don't even...
Premium manage.
Oh...
The one that I pay...
I pay yearly.
So it's, like...
A hundred...
Dollars...
A hundred Canadian dollars...
A year?
Mine's just premium.
But...
Um...
I basically...
I get, like...
Um...
I don't know how much that is with each month, but...
Every month...
I make, like...
Like, how much did I make last time?
Yeah...
Oh, it's eight dollars a month.
Yeah, it's eight dollars Canadian a month.
But...
I don't mind telling you guys what I get.
Um...
Each month...
I get...
Around...
Seventy...
To a hundred dollars a month.
So, like...
Each month...
I basically get an extra year of premium.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At this point where I think that...
When that feature came out...
It was extremely predatory to learn.
It's sort of depressing, to be honest.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, so, like...
It was just...
Yeah, that's, like, at least one Uber meal per month.
Yeah, I should have...
I should have, like...
Done...
I should have fixed that...
Earlier.
Because I stopped.
I stopped.
I...
Like, when they asked for, like...
Your ID...
Pictures of your ID and stuff.
It was around...
July 5th, 2024.
Because that's where it stopped.
And then I was, like...
I was just, like...
And I just got lazy.
Because my ID was, like, in my wallet.
And at that time...
My wallet was, like, pretty far.
Like, was in the next room.
And I was, like...
I'll do that tomorrow.
And then I never did that tomorrow.
And then...
And then that tomorrow never happened.
Like...
Last month, I was, like...
Oh, yeah.
I should really do that.
I should...
Literally a year later.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
A year later.
On July 4th, 2025.
I finally registered my ID on Twitter.
I was, like, happy anniversary and birthday.
I guess I should just give them my ID.
Yippee!
Finally.
Acrox.
Is this real?
Should I upload ID to questionable companies?
I'm...
Oh, they already have it.
They already have my information.
I...
I'm feeling cute today.
I might show my ID to Twitter.
Um...
Oh, my God.
It's already been two hours?
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
I know I'm, like, super behind.
But, like...
Oh, my gosh.
I'm, like, thinking.
Do I talk about this?
Like...
I'm thinking, like...
No, maybe I shouldn't talk about this.
Guys.
It was so wild when Elmo got hacked.
I can't believe they hacked Elmo.
I...
That was...
That was so wild.
Okay.
My favorite...
I know, like, there's a favorite part, Dookie.
But, like...
My favorite...
Like...
When I found out about Elmo...
Elmo was so wild.
But, like...
My favorite part...
About the Elmo hack...
Was because...
I found out...
From the screenshot...
Like...
Because I was...
You know, like...
Like, the quote retweet...
And I was like...
Yeah, from the smile...
Yeah...
It was...
It was crazy.
I was like...
Elmo...
No!
What happened, Elmo?
Please!
You can't...
After getting canceled, Elmo went off the deep end.
Yeah, they hacked Elmo.
That's crazy.
Out of any account...
I would assume...
To be fair...
To be fair, though...
I would assume...
The...
Um...
I would assume...
The...
Um...
The security...
For Elmo's...
Elmo's account...
From fucking Sesame Street...
That...
Is not...
Tight.
Like, that's...
I...
I swear to god...
I feel like I can...
Like, imagine the scenario...
On how...
Elmo's account got hacked.
But just...
Some guy...
Literally just sent a phishing email...
To like...
The...
The Sesame Street...
Social media...
Workers...
And then the guy just clicked on a link...
And then got the account!
I...
I feel like...
I feel like it's not that difficult to hack Elmo.
If you think about like...
Like...
Sesame Street...
I...
100% bet you...
That...
That's how Elmo got hacked.
They literally just sent a phishing email...
To like...
The Sesame Street...
Social media workers...
And...
I assume they do not get paid that much...
Because...
It's public...
TV...
And like...
Cause like...
You know...
It's PBS...
Public Broadcasting...
It's public broadcasting...
Like...
And...
I assume they don't get paid that much...
To like...
Properly check the...
The links that they get sent...
Yeah...
Hahaha...
So like...
I'm not...
I'm not surprised...
That that happened...
It was just...
It was...
It was so fucking crazy...
When that happened...
Yeah...
Hahaha...
Okay...
Before I talk...
I was gonna say...
I'm so sad that the UNO thing wasn't real...
And it was just...
A lie...
I can't believe people would lie on the internet...
And UNO had to make a statement...
Be like...
Okay...
I don't...
They were like...
Yeah...
No...
We're not...
We're not being...
Played at casino games...
Hahaha...
So...
Um...
There was a...
Temporary...
Setup...
For UNO...
For like...
Competitive...
Like...
Gambling...
Uno for gambling...
But it was only there for...
Two days...
Apparently...
Um...
So...
It was basically like...
Um...
Basically...
But it was only for two days...
At one casino...
Um...
As like a special promotion...
Or something...
And then...
And then everybody thought they were actually introducing UNO...
To like...
Uh...
Casinos in Las Vegas...
Um...
So everyone was like...
Freaking out...
Because like...
Hahaha...
I...
I love this...
There was this tweet...
That was like...
When you lose a thousand dollars...
Because you forgot to say UNO...
Like...
Just imagine...
I would watch that...
Not gonna lie...
I feel like competitive UNO...
Is...
Like competitive UNO...
With gambling...
Is...
Might be much more interesting to watch...
Than actual poker...
Because imagine you...
Imagine like...
You're locked in...
Because you have to say UNO...
You're like...
Okay...
This guy...
Like in your head...
You're doing your own mind palace thing...
And in your head...
You're just like...
Okay...
This guy...
He has two cards...
If it's the reverse card...
And then...
That means...
Um...
If it's...
He puts...
Two blue ones...
Then...
That means he's gonna have one card...
So I have to get ready...
To say UNO...
When he puts those two cards down...
The mo...
And then...
It's just like...
The...
Like...
The amount of like...
Of...
Thinking...
And like...
Prediction...
You have to do...
And then like...
Having a...
Poker face...
For fucking UNO...
Like...
Oh yeah...
And then counting cards...
And you're like...
Okay...
So this guy...
So we've currently put down...
Five...
Plus twos...
There's only six...
Left...
There's only...
There's...
Six plus twos...
In the deck...
Um...
So only one person has...
One more plus two...
Uh...
God...
Code...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
Yeah...
But yeah...
I just thought it was fuck killer...
Imagine just losing...
Just cause you forgot to say...
Ooh, no, that's gonna be so... that's so fucked up.
But anyway, this was... okay, I just realized what time it is.
And I did say today might be a short stream, but this is my last thing I want to talk about.
But I just found out that the dog... the dog in Superman is motion-captured.
I was like... and I thought it was so fucking funny because like...
there's... because like I saw the super dog scenes like Krypto.
And I was like, oh my god, that's a real person.
It's like, yeah, yeah, someone was actually... was like motion...
Yeah, someone actually like motion-captured Krypto in Superman.
Like, so now like... now for me, it's like a little weird because now I...
Because all I can think about is how like...
There's a... like, if it was CGI, it's like less weird, I guess.
But then I'm like, there's a real person behind that trying to pretend to be a dog.
Like, I won't... it's like that...
It's like the Twilight scene.
Uh...
It's like that...
Twilight scene...
No, they motion-captured a person.
It's a real person.
I'll show you the like...
It's a real person behind the dog.
I am just like...
It's like reminding me of that Twilight scene...
Where...
What was her name?
Belle was like...
Um...
Was like petting...
Jacob's head.
Because he was a wolf and it is...
It just reminded me of that fucking scene.
And that's all I could think about.
You guys...
Okay, Twilight...
Twilight...
It's...
It's such a classic motion-capture.
It's actually such a...
I love that...
I love that picture so much.
But that's all I could think about.
That's all...
That's all I could think about.
They didn't release any photos of it, but...
Wait, let me...
Save.
It's such a good...
It's such a good picture too.
It really is.
It's such a good picture.
I love it.
But, I'm just thinking how it's like that, but for... but for Superman instead.
Oh yeah, no, I saw the Benedict Cumber Cabbage Patch Kids thing.
This is like...
But that's...
That's all I could think about when I found out that Crypto was motion captured by...
By a child?
I don't know.
Teenager?
Young woman?
But those are like, what did it look like?
This is what it's supposed to look like.
Oh my god, I've never seen these photos.
Wait, these photos are so good.
Wait a minute.
These photos are actually so good.
Sorry.
Some of this is like, really fucking good.
And it's so funny to see it again.
Alright, um...
Let's see.
I'm trying to find a good picture for us.
For us.
Alright, this one.
So this is what it's supposed to be.
And then this...
This is what it turned out.
I love this picture.
I don't know.
I love this picture so fucking much.
It lives in my head.
I like think about it sometimes.
It lives in my head, Renfri.
I'll be like, oh my gosh.
Remember that time?
Twilight did a motion capture of Jacob on his werewolf form?
And then he's just...
And then she's just fucking touching his...
Rubbing his head?
You mean it wasn't...
It wasn't a real wolf?
Like...
I can't believe it wasn't a real wolf, guys.
Anyway.
I'm gonna call it here, guys.
Have fun time chatting with y'all.
I hope y'all have fun time hanging out with me today.
Um...
I am gonna have to get back to work.
Like I said, there's so much behind the scenes stuff to do.
There's a lot behind the scenes stuff to do.
So I hope you guys look forward to NASCAR week.
Um...
But I hope you guys still have fun.
I know...
I know some of you guys like...
Do enjoy my sponsor stream.
Because, you know...
Um...
There's a lot of like fun stuff to do there.
And, um...
I try my best to make it fun for you guys.
And...
Um...
And, you know...
Hang out with my dragoons.
So...
Um...
I look forward to the rest of the week!
Tomorrow's collab, though.
Tomorrow is Mario Party with...
Um...
I got invited to it.
Uh...
I think...
I got invited to it.
And I was like, sure, no problem.
Um...
But...
Tomorrow...
Um...
That one was also took a while to plan.
Because, um...
Zentrayo's going through a lot.
Um...
You know, over the last couple of weeks.
So...
I literally like...
Got notified...
About the...
The...
Like...
Who...
Who I'm collabing with.
And like...
The time and date.
Like...
Last night.
That's why I also couldn't put the schedule up.
Because like...
I was waiting for confirmation.
Um...
Uh...
For...
Like...
Basically every day.
I had to wait for confirmation.
Like...
Every...
All the streams for this week.
I was waiting for confirmation on stuff.
Um...
Yeah.
So...
Uh...
Tomorrow will be Mario Party.
With...
Zentraya...
Billion...
And...
Mari Mari.
So...
Yeah.
Uh...
They invited me and I was like...
Okay.
Sure.
Uh...
Um...
But yeah.
So that's tomorrow.
And then...
Wednesday...
Tuesday.
Thursday.
Thursday is two sponsors.
One is called...
Gold...
What is it called?
Got me to say it correctly.
Gold...
Uh...
Gold, gold, adventure, gold.
I forgot the third word.
I knew it was gold, gold, something gold.
Gold, gold, adventure gold.
On...
In the morning, in the afternoon, and in the evening.
It's uh...
Vida...
Vida Ramen.
Vida Ramen...
Um...
Launch for the merch.
With a special stream.
And then on...
Friday...
It's...
Special stream.
I didn't leak anything.
Uh...
Sponsor.
And then after that...
It'll be...
Sorry.
I'm like malfunctioning right now.
I'm actually so brain fried today.
Um...
I don't...
I think...
I feel like it's very noticeable.
Cause I'm stumbling a lot of my words.
Um...
And I'm saying a lot of fucking random shit today.
Like...
I'm all over the place.
My brain is so fried.
Like...
I'm so fried today.
Because of all the work that I have to do.
Uh...
My last brain cell is going...
Hey...
It's vibrating so hard today.
Uh...
See, I can't even say words.
I'm like, what's at chat?
Chat's my thesaurus now.
Chat is my thesaurus and dictionary.
Um, I won't say like, I'm censoring myself.
I'm restraining myself.
No, what's that word?
Ah!
I'm less filtered.
Yes!
I'm less filtered today.
I'm a lot less filtered.
I am not thinking about what I'm saying, which is bad.
Which is very bad.
But I, I don't have my, my mental filters are not on today.
Um, so, that's why I'm so all over the place.
Um, um, um, but yes.
Anyway.
Anyway, that's Thursday.
Or was that Friday?
Oh my gosh, I'm losing track of my days.
I'm ready.
So, that's Friday.
That's Friday.
And then after the special stream sponsor, it's Elden Ring.
And Saturday, it's the fake trigger sponsor.
So, and then if we do good, then Sunday is also another fake trigger sponsor.
If we make it to the finals.
So, we'll see how it goes.
But anyway, guys.
I hope you guys all have a great time with me today.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause the check.
Get up and around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed.
Cause, you deserve it.
Uh, I'll post the schedule up later today.
Cause I literally have it all written down.
Just didn't have the times on it.
So, but yeah.
I'll see you guys soon, everybody.
Or tomorrow.
I'll see you guys later.
Uh, everyone.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause the check.
Get up and around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed.
Cause, you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.